hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play the Attic chapter 2
all right week I think I'm actually in a
new area of the the town trying to try
to find a Bandhan house at the end of
the long path anything in their blood no
oh crap I'm back at the beginning again
Frick frack sassafras hello oh hello
wait ah wait what's this
ah ah ah look abandoned and it's a lie I
was all a lie it's a lot on him but
that's about it I was a lie
dirty dirty lie
fine whatever
I do what I want okay fine
tell me this house doesn't look
abandoned to you
it looks pretty abandoned to me ah where
my garden what am I to know stand on
that maple break
um that didn't scare me but I was
gasping at the fact that oh I think I'm
at I think this might be it oh dude dead
bunny mmm
all right fine you this way hi come on
drop their Charter than that
wha-ha-ha try not enough they'll look so
cocky
did it did it did okay okay
Dukey hi barrels ball from the ceiling
oh I got ya
hi I got you another one oh I gotcha
yeah ffs wasn't the barrels that does be
scary
this looks abandoned it's look oh yeah
why put it there of all the places why
their wine the last house the very last
house making the most inconvenient place
in the times of an evacuation hi barrel
okay I'll get it but whatever it's all
good barrel okay nope
okay so we are good we got the key we
can get in city hall we can make our way
to wherever the hell we're trying to go
I think we're trying to save people but
I don't care about them I aah all that
again god damn it's weird because I
thought in custom stories like this
things didn't reset but apparently in
this one they do even monsters reset
sometimes
Julio's ace screw your vase oh crap okay
I'm okay I'm okay
screw yo thanks bro yo face laughs oh
there we go easy oh yeah I'm the best
the best there ever will hello rattles
you'll glue yup mash
yeah oil
yeah victory oil hello rat mouse mouse
rat hard to tell in this game think he's
a rat hello tinderbox
once again it is exceptionally brightly
lit you know it's almost as if it seems
like it's day out except it wasn't who's
not day it was the opposite of day you
know that thing where the moon will rise
why won't this tunnel what kind of city
hall is this king's throne hello climb
climb climb climb climb climb climb
climb climb climb
what was this just so you know did they
just put that there because they knew
that people would climb up it they did
didn't they they did they did they
totally did
or maybe I need to like stealthily climb
around the edge here oh yeah or maybe if
I ooh maybe I could get up here not kink
it up there but I could yeah yeah all
right I gotcha
ah [ __ ] well I failed alright nevermind
then I was a stupid idea anyway
locked vo head and knock that head off
hello anybody home oh you are dead
outside dead people
anybody new tender box here into boxes
yeah I guess they're about to turn out
the lights
Let Me In [ __ ] you then more tuned to
boxes new king oh boy
the letter reads dear mr. mayor good
evening sir my name is Elle my name is
Alison later in the mansion just beyond
the town I've lived we have lived in for
about 50 70 years and love the way you
have been ruling the people he's a mayor
all right we're going to inform you that
my way with Libby Jackson has been
murdered this is not a typical murder
you sir I had to kill her don't take
this the wrong way allow me to explain
myself you see
you know I am in the Royal Army to
develop chemicals for healing
unfortunately my wife was getting
between my research and I all the time
she was about to tell the world about
some projects going on so I had no
option I have enclosed audre thousand
shillings in order for you to not pursue
any legal action against me my son Derek
or any of the Jackson family you could
have just kept it quiet I bet no one
would have known in that big mansion I
hope there's another worth of item you
to agreement I'm willing to offer more
if necessary your friend
destruction mayor's master key okay this
the mayor hey things pretty dad man
Ellis Jackson's voice making my throat
hurt all right okay then yeah yeah yeah
yeah
dark dark dark dark dark dark dark deep
infinite really really freakin long I
don't look forward to coming back I hope
I don't have to come back up anything
under the stairs oh oh oh away hojae
oh hello here we go it's not under the
stairs but ah no there we go
it's a little little little mannequin
American lives a little mannequin
Jahlil mannequin
I don't like this it's awfully quiet too
big room ah ah [ __ ] yeah hello give me
give give
oh there's nothing in here anyway Thank
You Ches I knew I knew it was too quiet
the current looks too strong it would be
smart for me to stay out of our Oh
[ __ ] police oh uh yeah I have to
carry on whatever whatever
I don't care I don't care oh I'm on the
backup here hello no oh I thought I
thought the monsters were responding her
up so I guess I got rid of that monster
he saw I jumped in the water he's like
oh we got a badass over here whoa so he
didn't want to mess with me
there's nothing that oh yeah there's ah
sassafras oh I gotta walk I can jump
this yeah oh yeah so epic ah yeah get
all the ladies
huh huh huh tinderbox
hello bottom first nothing's gonna get
me nothin gonna gay it's a picture of
testing as a kid yeah that is a really
effeminate picture of Derek he's Derek
he's hey buddy
I'm goin he's the best I've ever seen
working and warehouse pumping diesel
gasoline anybody remember that whose
line whose line any whose line pans out
there nobody's better nobody's better
than Derek no ha ha ha tinderbox can't
beat me if you do if you do take an
Internet high-five for yourself because
you are awesome for liking cruise lines
anybody who's a big fan of whose line is
a friend of mine Oh fake Falls
hello baby how you doing oh yeah
long time no no see
where's done oh hello dead guy get tired
of seeing them guys go to the bed
no oh oh oh [ __ ] balls no aah no come in
here don't do it buddy nobody don't do
it buddy okay there was
this man oh go away go away
good thing I double-checked for that key
yes I would have totally missed it
things still Donna no he's gone okay
we're good
what if we're good for now nope oh it's
a dead grunt I say dead grunt okay okay
okay good okay okay hello that's weird
but he's gonna bust open Wow
what these are different models look
like the little kids actually weird the
torture room huh yeah there we go oh I
probably shouldn't go down there I can't
go down there hello mr. moose oh wow
this is kind of gross seems a pretty big
place for City Hall you think some
people would have asked some questions
oh of course those are probably the
people that ask questions laudanum not
that I ever use it I just end up either
dying right away or I recover health
over time anyway you think this guy
wouldn't leave his prized invention
invention invention just laying about
everywhere okay I got the machine room
key what does that mean is it the thing
over here the thing over here they're
doing you huh
I dunno oh there was nothing over here
anyway
hello is anybody there
[Music]
epically come on damn it
leap anyway no one of their mother oh
maybe I don't know somewhere over here
oh no is it hat get rid of your head
show me I'm 2 points if I went in there
and there that's where I got the key
oh maybe over here ah yeah this is it
this is what we've all been waiting for
and I run out of time sorry [ __ ]
thanks you everyone for watching thank
you everybody for watching and as always
I'll see you in the next part
bye bye